um when do you think women start to
lower their standards if ever
at what age
I didn't want to believe it when I heard
Kevin Samuel say 60 because I thought
that was so far off but I really do
believe because we have this thing you
know black don't crack or whatever I'm
still 47 in three years I'll be half a
hundred I should move differently than
someone that's 27 so I would say women
mistakenly think
I can still compete in that Arena so I
shouldn't have to settle and then you
end up in your 50s and 60s alone and
then you say okay I'll just be happy to
have anyone she's she's telling the
truth so I'm 41 and this is the reality
I I have young guys I mean like young
like Ballers NBA like guys who are we
like early 20s who will hit me up want
to take me out and all of this and a lot
of women who still can carry a little
bit as they get older they're still in
shape they're getting hit up by these
young guys and you think you still have
it because these guys will want to sleep
with you they'll even take you out there
I mean they'll even buy you something to
do they're not going to marry you and a
lot of women just like the glamor of it
and they feel like they still got it and
they don't realize these guys are just
using you for easy sex and so because
they're sleeping with you and they're
attracted to you that translates in your
mind that I got it like I'm still in the
game I know women who are like 50 and
older who actually look amazing like no
lie like I know these women have women
in my family who look this way and if
they wanted to but most of them in my
family are married but if they wanted to
they they could attract they're 50 they
can attract a 30 year old guy and so it
is not until they hit where it starts to
crack and and guys are just like man 60
uh you can't do that that's six that six
puts a hurt even if a guy wanted to I
was just gonna say they can attract him
but they can't keep him and ultimately
that's what we want at the end of the
day we're not just supposed to be out
here floating around from man to man we
are supposed to be tethered and attached
and belong to someone and I think that's
normal and that's natural we just have
to do a better job of making the
distinction between attention and
intention that's right sexual sexual is
sexual attraction versus relationship
intention and a lot of women cannot tell
the difference so I'm curious you said
you're 21 yeah would you say what
they're talking about do you see that
with your friends where they'll sleep
with someone that's out of their league
or that someone famous will DM them yeah
and you know it happens it's happened to
me but because I know that rappers
footballers basketball players I'm just
not into that because I know that
they're not going to be available to me
so but my friends on the other hand
they're more
yeah well they um fly out to someone
where they don't know yeah I'm curious
and you don't have to say this if you
don't want to how many guys has a girl
your age slept with usually like not you
but just in general
um
now around 15. oh my God are you 21
so she's not even 21 yet guys and you
would say the average girl I'm not
saying yeah me personally has only been
one but yeah but girls your age it's
like 15 to 20. yeah plus and how many
how many did were they in relationships
with
none it's mainly situationships now so
you know shout out to feminism and would
you would you agree that it's like
mostly the same guys that they're all
sleeping with yeah but then every time
someone does them run back they start
catching feelings this guy's like okay
well I don't want a relationship with
you they're like okay I'm gonna up my
standards wow and then to wear why do I
love her so much guys she's so pretty
too thank you sorry okay keep talking
sorry she is so cute yeah they um they
up their standards and
when there's someone that like maybe a
rapper footballer messages them they're
just like they hop on it and then it's
like a cycle the same thing happens
where that guy just doesn't want her for
what she wants and do most of the time
do the men tell the women up front that
they're not looking for anything yeah
but they still believe that I can change
it yeah feminism
would you agree that it's mostly on the
women then because the guy said up front
what they're looking for yeah
and why did you make a different Choice
what made you be in a relationship with
a lot of your friends are in the streets
because I just I you know I'm I'm very
traditional I want marriage and I just
don't I'm just not into the whole rapper
scene I'm very private I like to keep
myself to myself so I'm just not not
into it yo older women we have to
protect their protect her I feel like
you're like my daughter I believe son
you ain't gonna feminism
okay don't put that on me that's your
trauma on I'm protecting but baby right
here yeah reach out I will talk to her
absolutely that's my job feminism has
disguised female empowerment through
sexual Liberation and acted like that
thing is the damn truth how it's
delusional do you create this idea that
these guys are telling you this is not
what I want and you try to change the
damn Minds that mean that makes no damn
sense to me at the end of the day you
need to look at your results
and if you are 15 guys deep
15 15
large sweating
young men you know that's love humping
that's love aggressively okay
um
I forgot that was my channel for a
second you know what I mean
that's what I demonetized me
what she said is it's so important for
young women to speak up like that and
even what Maggie is saying it's almost
like you can you can you can see the
wisdom you can see that coming out and
what will happen is with a girl like her
if her mind wasn't right or she wasn't
open to things she would be influenced
to go to the streets and so many other
young women are influencing their
friends to go to the streets because
they want to be validated in what
they're doing they don't want somebody
doing better being wifed up because then
then I have to look at myself and like
there's a bit of jealousy that she has a
boyfriend maybe even put your boyfriend
down I've cut off a lot of people but I
actually don't have any friends even my
cousins I've had to cut them off
completely wow because they've they're
going through hard times like
my cousin's been with someone for six
years and they're not in a relationship
and he cheats and he just uses her then
they look at me and they get really
jealous and that's why I just had to cut
them off but that's so dangerous right
because we need Community we need so
please connect with her and get that
mentorship and get that yes because we
need that we need people who are going
to reach down and educate us and show us
that it's different we need men who are
going to look at us and say hey that
ain't cool don't be out here giving it
to these boys don't be doing this right
and that's why I keep going to the whole
it's a circle of effect right it's not
just focusing on one end it's it's a
role that both are called to play yes we
absolutely have to take accountability
as a woman and I love that at 21 I'm you
know approaching 21
um that you are doing that that you are
mature that this is wisdom talking if we
go out on these streets even in America
I can't come across an average 21 year
old who thinks like you do that is so
rare you are a unicorn in today's
society we don't exist right so I love
that that's why I would say there are
more more husbands today when a man
finds a woman whose mind is right and
talks like that even young she is so
valuable out here even like a man will
will let go of a lot of things I talked
to a lot of high value men in terms of
what they're looking for and I say will
you will you like you know I don't need
a 10 I will take a seven I will even
take a six I will take a woman if she
has the right mind and I know I can
trust her and I'm safe with her and
she's going to be a good mother and a
good wife I'll take that all day over
these IG models who are just worth
nothing and and and these men they can
run through them and it just becomes
boring it just becomes they're intrigued
by a woman who has character and quality
and a lot of these young women are not
understanding this even men that you
think are absolutely for the street if
they come again they've come across
character and quality they are just like
they cannot they feel like it's a
unicorn but there are more men who are
ready than there are how many young
women talk like this how many young men
are actually virgins compared to young
women who are 21 they're not women can
get sex everywhere that's why the body
count is high have you ever spoken to
your friends but maybe that's not the
best like path to go down and how do
they react they're like well they just
they don't listen then the thing is they
get hurt they run to me and then the
next day they're talking to them again
and then it's kind of dragging me down
and it's the energy and I just don't
want that energy one of the reasons why
we don't listen to women out here guys
okay because uh women will say a lot of
things like you said they would say oh I
hate him he's this he's that next week
they're back they're back with him why
did they do that though girl you know
because women are led by their emotions
and they want validation for men right
well they're led by their emotions
if a guy
gets cheated on right his luggage kicks
in he said okay what is it like what did
she do how did it go down oh my God that
makes me feel sick oh I can't be around
it anymore a woman
is she wants that like you said she
wants that validation she's emotionally
attached to somebody and she will let
that lead and she will she doesn't think
about the things that men think about
when when they get cheated on I'd like
to answer your question why why do women
do that I think it's because women we
just want everything and we wanna we
wanna you know as women you know we want
to think that we're who's that Ronaldo
guy's wife what's her face that was
working at a shoe store
do you know what I'm talking about
anyone know her name yeah
Georgina Georgina you know I think women
in general were narcissistic and we all
think that we're more important than we
are and we also think that we can change
men as she said and we all think we're
CR whatever Ronaldo so even if a man
hasn't wife the last 50 girls 100 girls
200 women we're all just think that
we're special and that we're gonna be
the 201st that just changes him and
occasionally you know there's a Ronaldo
chick that gets lucky and then all the
girls point at the Sierras and the
Ronaldo checks and just say well they
did it so I can do it but
you don't look like her right so you
won't have that outcome and then when
you try to tell him that
they just don't listen and do it again
yeah
I don't think it's even determined on
women like a lot of times when a man is
ready for a wife the next woman that
comes along that meets the criteria that
he's looking for he will get married
it's it may not even dependent on
because she's so special it's just that
she's meeting certain criteria that he
can work with and when a man is ready
men own marriage they own relationship
we own sex so if a man wants marriage he
is tired of the streets he wants a wife
and his mind is set on that the next
girl that comes along that offers at
least a large portion at least the
majority of the things that he's looking
for he will settle down and that's why
women will say why is he with her she's
not even that fine she's not that bad
his ex-girlfriend looked better and we
will start talking about the looks we
don't even women talk about like why are
men so concerned about looks we will dog
a woman out who is with a man that we
want who is high value and say well
she's not as fine and like people down
the street like my neighbor looks better
I look better than her she's not even a
bad B but yet we will get mad at men and
say they focus on looks but that we
don't understand the psychology of men
when they're tired men can just go right
now of all of us women in here
it's a dry season we just we need some d
to the streets probably even to the
dudes in here we can go outside and say
listening
but no this is what women are if we go
out if I go outside if all of us women
go outside right now and we just walk up
to random dudes and like listen
uh you can come to my hotel you can come
to my room come to my apartment I I need
some D let's let's get it in we can just
get it we can go to a club and just we
can wear a sign and say hey come get
this and we will get it if a man wore
that women are not running up to that
man we're scared we're running away
we're like terrified it will some men be
terrified yes but for the most part men
are gonna come flocking lining up for
that and it comes to marriage if a man
came on and said listen I need a wife I
want a woman I want to be dedicated to
her I want to I'm gonna be faithful I
want to do that women will come running
out of the woodwork so men own
relationship and marriage and whoever
comes next if you if you line up enough
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible